-As the FBI investigators
sexual-assault allegations
against Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh,
it's become clear
that he is very much
like the president
who nominated him.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Kavanaugh allegations,
perhaps more
than any other story,
have made Republicans
absolutely lose their minds.
In the last week, we've seen a
nominee for the Supreme Court
scream and cry
in a Senate hearing,
Senators threaten
their colleagues,
and the President gave multiple
rambling press conferences
that were so incoherent, even
the closed captioning gave up.
[ Laughter and applause ]
And one of the surest signs
that Trump is losing his mind
over the Kavanaugh crisis
is that he's accusing
everyone else of going crazy.
Trump always deflects criticism
by projecting onto others
whatever he's accused of,
and lately,
he's even adopted
a new catch phrase.
-They have been blind --
in a blind rage --
ever since, boy,
they lost the 2016 election.
They've gone loco.
They have gone loco.
These people,
they've gone crazy.
They've gone loco.
-When I won,
I said, "The good thing is
now the press finally gets it.
Now they'll finally
treat me fairly."
They got worse.
They're worse now than ever.
They're loco.
But that's okay.
I put up with it.
Go ahead.
I use that word
because of the fact
that we made a deal with Mexico.
-Oh, is that why?
[ Audience groans ]
Is that why you used it?
"We had meetings with Mexico,
and they were using
the word 'loco' a lot.
Apparently --"
[ Laughter ]
Apparently, it's their word
for 'president.'"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, why does he point
to his head when he says loco?
[ Laughter ]
He can't even do
basic hand gestures right.
And what is this thing
he does all the time?
Just some jackass version
of jazz hands.
[ Laughter ]
Like he's dancing
next to Shirley Temple.
[ Laughter ]
Trump reminds me
of an '80s movie
where an alien
crash lands on Earth
and tries
to learn human culture.
I'd love to see him
flip someone off.
"Hey, man, F you."
[ Laughter ]
Trump is going loco,
because, in Kavanaugh,
he very much sees himself --
a powerful man
who's led a privileged life,
who's never before been held
accountable for his actions,
suddenly being challenged
over his treatment of women.
In fact, yesterday,
Trump pretty much spelled it out
when he was asked
if he had a message
for young men in America.
-Well, I'd say that it's
a very scary time
for young men in America
when you can be
guilty of something
that you may not be guilty of.
Somebody could accuse you
of something,
and you're automatically guilty.
But in this realm, you are truly
guilty until proven innocent.
-Oh, you suddenly care
about due process
and the presumption
of innocence?
Because when
you mention Hillary Clinton
at your most recent rally,
your supporters
were still chanting this.
No, I'm sure they meant to
chant, "Lock her up only after
a fair trail in which
overwhelming evidence
of wrongdoing is presented."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I mean, obviously,
it's a little longer, but...
[ Applause ]
Also, it's so sad that they're
still chanting "Lock her up."
Let it go.
Hillary's out there
selling books,
sipping Chardonnay,
and making cameos
on "Murphy Brown,"
and you guys are all crammed
into a local civic center,
watching the world's
sweatiest man have an aneurysm.
[ Laughter ]
Kavanaugh's also lied repeatedly
about his heavy drinking
in high school and college days.
Trump was asked about that
and decided to talk instead
about his own decision
to abstain from alcohol.
-Well, I don't drink.
I've never had a drink.
I don't drink beer.
I've never had a beer.
And I'm not saying good or bad.
Some people like it.
I just chose not to do that
for a lot of reasons.
I think that...
I remember my college days.
Everybody was drinking.
It was like normal.
I was abnormal.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, we're aware of that.
We all know you're abnormal.
And "abnormal"
is the best word for Trump,
because it's how you describe
a weird mole, you know?
"What do you think, doc?"
"Well, it's definitely abnormal.
It's red, irritated, and all
the hair is falling out."
So Republicans have been
losing their minds
over the Kavanaugh allegations,
and last night,
Trump took his meltdown
to a new level -- openly mocking
Dr. Christine Blasey Ford's
testimony
at a rally in Mississippi.
-36 years ago, this happened.
"I had one beer, right?
I had one beer."
"Well, you think it was --"
"No, it was one beer."
"Oh, good.
How did you get home?"
"I don't remember."
"How'd you get there?"
"Where is the place?"
"I don't remember."
"How many years ago was it?"
"I don't know.
I don't know."
[ Cheers and applause ]
"I don't know.
I don't know."
"What neighborhood was it in?"
"I don't know."
"Where's the house?"
"Upstairs, downstairs,
where was it?"
"I don't know.
But I had one beer.
That's the only thing
I remember."
-I mean, that's the President
of the United States
openly mocking a survivor
of sexual assault.
There's no rock bottom
for this guy.
Rock bottom
is where he jumped from.
And let this be a lesson --
Let this be a lesson to everyone
who is praising Trump
for his supposedly
respectful handling of Dr. Ford.
You knew this was coming.
It's like a werewolf movie
where someone says,
"He hasn't turned into a wolf
for 29 days,
so I think we're good."
[ Laughter ]
"Unlock his bedroom."
Seriously, man,
what's wrong with you?
Look at him --
red-faced, sweaty.
Trump's never
had a drink in his life,
and somehow,
he's still an angry drunk.
And by the way,
your little re-enactment
of Ford's testimony
was wrong anyway.
Just because you
don't remember the details
doesn't mean she didn't.
Her testimony
under unimaginable trauma
was searing and yet somehow
still incredibly composed.
Meanwhile, if someone asked you
one question
at a press conference,
you melt down like you just saw
the Arc of the Covenant.
-Should the FBI interview
all three of Brett Kavanaugh's
accusers?
-Aaaaaaah!
-And much like Kavanaugh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Much like Kavanaugh,
Trump has also repeatedly lied
about the allegations
against him,
like the hush payment
to Stormy Daniels
that Trump's personal fixer
Michael Cohen made
in the closing days
of the campaign.
Remember when Trump said he had
absolutely nothing
to do with that payment,
and then his lawyer went on TV
and said he did know
and then took it back
and said he didn't know,
and then Trump said he did know
and then said his lawyer
was wrong when he said he knew?
-They funneled it
through a law firm.
-Funneled through a law firm,
and the President repaid it.
-Excuse me, excuse me,
excuse me.
No, but you have to --
Excuse me.
You take a look at what I said.
You go back and take a look.
You'll see what I said.
You go take a look
at what we said.
-Yeah, dude.
You were asked if you knew about
the payment, and you said no.
We saw it, remember?
You were standing
in the aisle of the plane
like you were about to take
everyone's drink orders.
"Oh, I'll just have a snack."
"We don't have snacks."
"You just said you did."
"Go back and take a look
at what I said."
[ Laughter ]
Then, of course, it turned out
that Trump was directly involved
in the payment,
and then, on Tuesday,
we found out that, in February,
while he was President,
Trump had personally sought
to keep Stormy Daniels quiet.
-A source with direct knowledge
tells CNN
President Trump
personally directed an effort
to keep porn star
Stormy Daniels quiet
about a sexual encounter she
says she had with him in 2006.
In February, the President
called his now former
personal attorney Michael Cohen
and instructed him
to seek a restraining order
against Daniels.
The source says
Trump directed Cohen
to coordinate the effort
involving his son, Eric Trump,
and an outside lawyer.
-You put Eric on the case?
[ Laughter ]
I'm not surprised
the cover-up failed.
I'm surprised we didn't end up
with video from three angles
and a signed confession.
[ Laughter ]
So, to recap,
Trump personally intervened
to keep a porn star
from speaking publicly
about an affair
he illegally covered up
during a presidential campaign,
and he put his
two dumbest subordinates on it.
Although, in fairness,
it's not like
Trump's surrounded by geniuses.
"We need to stop
this Stormy thing.
Who's the smartest guy here?
Me?
Oh. That's not good."
[ Laughter and applause ]
These guys lie --
They lie to hold on to power
because they think
they're entitled to it.
That's why they're all furious
and indignant
when you question them
in any way.
If you suggest that they
broke the law
to become president
or they shouldn't sit
on the Supreme Court,
they go absolutely...
-Loco.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]